hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be
talking about Selena cysteine and pyro
lysine these are sometimes called the
21st and 22nd proto genic amino acids so
let's talk about what that means
basically there are hundreds of non
amino acids that have different
functions in biology but only 22 of them
are what is known as protein o genic
this means that they are incorporated
into proteins
during the process of translation now of
these 22 there are 20 that you're
probably already really familiar with
those are part of the standard genetic
code sometimes called the universal
genetic code you've probably seen that
table where you've got all of the
triplet codons that shows you what each
triplet codon which amino acid it codes
for so those are the 20 that we're
talking about here now there's two more
and those are the subject of today's
video that is Selena cysteine and pyro
lysine and those aren't incorporated
still during translation but via special
translation mechanisms so they're not
part of that standard genetic code now
let's take a look at what these two
amino acids look like we'll talk about
the one it's typically numbered as
number 21 first that's Celino cysteine
this is what Selena cysteine looks like
so just help orient you we've got our
alpha carbon right there over the alkyl
carbon and an amino acid is attached to
four things you've got the amino group
the hydrogen the carboxyl group and the
R group and instantly now cysteine this
right here is the R group it's known as
a seal in all group and
look familiar to you the ch2 selenium
and then hydrogen this right here is
very similar to the R group insisting
except that in cysteine instead of a
selenium you have a sulfur that cysteine
is the one that makes it disulfide
bridges you might be familiar with but
in salina cysteine we've got a selenium
here instead this selenium is very very
important it's actually an essential
dietary micronutrient meaning that our
bodies cannot make it we have to ingest
it in our diet and the reason it's so
essential is because Celino cysteine
this amino acid right here is used in
Celino proteins
so Cellino proteins are just proteins
that have Celino cysteine in them Celina
proteins in general has a lot of very
important functions in the brain if this
is something that you're interested in
you can go check out mercury poisoning
the reason that we worry about mercury
levels and taking in you know eating too
much safe fish that has mercury in it
sometimes is because that mercury can
bind up Celino proteins and keep them
from working effectively Celino cysteine
is found in all three domains but not in
all lineages it means that there are
certain groups of organisms and these
domains that don't actually use Celino
proteins but humans are certainly ones
that do use celina proteins and thus
have to make Celino cysteine when we are
referring to Celino cysteine using the
the three-letter abbreviation for amino
acids its SEC using the one letter
abbreviation you is the one letter
abbreviation that has been designated
for Celino cysteine now we'll move on to
number 22 and remember we're talking
about number 22 of these 22 proto genic
protein the genetic amino acids so this
one right here is pyro lysine you can
see it's a little bit more complicated
we've still got our alpha carbon right
there the alpha carbon still has its
amino group it's hydrogen its carboxyl
group this right here is the R group so
you have four ch2 groups and then a
nitrogen and this probably looks
familiar to you as well this is what
lysine would look like I said lysine has
two hydrogens connected to this nitrogen
and in pyro lysine one of those
hydrogen's has been replaced with this
right here which is a pyro lean group
and so this is paralyzing it is not as
common throughout living organisms as
Selena
cystine it's most well known for being
used in some antigens methanogens being
a type of extrema file bacterium it's
not used in humans at all
it's three-letter abbreviations pyl and
it's one letter abbreviation is o so now
that we know a little bit more about
Celino cysteine and pyro lysine let's
talk about how they actually get
incorporated in translation in other
words what are their special translation
mechanisms well it turns out that they
are both coded for by stop codons so if
you have studied biology for a while you
will know that there are three different
stop codons and those are codons that
when the ribosome gets to a stop codon
during translation is thought to the
translation process typically that means
that the the protein is complete and can
be released but in these special
circumstances there can be a stop codon
that instead of being interpreted as a
stop codon is interpreted as being for a
pyro lysine or acelino cysteine instead
and so pyro lysine is encoded by you a G
and Celino cysteine is encoded by you G
a and so those are the codons that are
typically stop codons but in certain
cases which we'll go over right here
they can instead direct the cell to
incorporate a pyro lysine or acelino
cysteine instead so we'll talk about the
pyro lysine one first and they organisms
that you spiral icing like methanogens
for example have a special gene cluster
so this is a grouping of genes it's
called the the pyl or Pyle TS BCD gene
cluster these code for
special enzymes and those special
enzymes help the translation machinery
recognize you AG as requiring a pyro
lacing to be incorporated instead of
recognizing it as a stop codon salinas
cysteine is encoded even in a different
way and so encoded by that ug a codon
that would usually be a stop codon but
there is a special kind of structure
it's about sixty nucleotides long called
the Cellino cysteine insertion sequence
or Cesis in the mRNA before the the UGA
codon and so basically what that looks
like is you've got about sixty
nucleotides and the mRNA and they form a
sort of special stem was called a stem
loop structure right before that UGA
codon and the presence of this structure
this right here being the Saline
assisting an insertion sequence tells
the cell hey don't read this as a stop
codon read it as requiring a cellino's
cysteine to be incorporated at that
place and so that is what the cell will
do in those circumstances if you're
interested in learning more about the
standard universal genetic code check
out my video on the genetic code if
you're interested in the way that mRNA
gets modified particularly post
transcriptionally modified and you can
also check out my videos on
post-transcriptional modifications to
see what other modifications the cell
makes to its mRNA prior to translation
so that's it for today I hope you
enjoyed watching and thanks for watching
biology professor